and there was a man behind me pressing
into me how did you know it was a man
because he was making some strange
noises that sounded male
and he was large so I assumed it was a
male okay he was large
I felt all my back
pressing
intentional assault of a sexual nature
right okay
um
was he grinding and thrusting or
something or just the noises what's what
what made you think it was a a sexual
assault so that was a quick thought that
went through my head when I was trying
to reconcile what was happening I was
skiing and two skis came between my skis
forcing my legs apart and then there was
a body pressing against me and there was
a very strange grunting noise so my
brain was trying to make sense of what
was happening